chaos if i could describe the film in
one word it would be chaos with the
ever-changing storyline delays and new
challenges that arose with the universe
cracking wide open in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness it's no
surprise that getting this movie made
was pure and utter chaos are you ready
to hear about the insanity they endured
to get it made
mcu as a whole that i just really want
them to throw out what they want next
number one the multiverse is real in our
world too multiple films shooting at the
same time led to the script not being
finalized until the shooting day and
even then things were changing on the
spot anything that didn't change in the
filming of this film was the title now
that they're moving into this huge new
phase of the multiverse where they are
drawing off other productions that are
overlapping like spider-man and
wandavision there could be a ripple
effect which would cause doctor
strange's script to change to keep up
with continuity that's another added
complication to an already complicated
piece so essentially they couldn't nail
down their ending until all of the
pieces were known and were writing the
script as they went we imagine they had
an ever evolving draft of the script and
weren't just working with 30 pages and
hoping it all came together if there was
no draft then they at least had their
plot points locked in elizabeth olsen
had very little idea what people would
even see in theaters the script changed
a lot right and i don't really know what
what it changed to olson jumped right
from wanda vision into the multiverse
the pitch she received was mind-blowing
i was terrified it just sounded like
such a challenge for her it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie and olsen had a ton of
questions about how the multiverse
worked palmer did too we imagine one of
those questions was is what if actually
part of the canon
number two benedict cumberbatch acting
opposite himself was a unique challenge
for him it doesn't get weirder than
playing doctor strange he joked about
his other self being lazy and hanging
out in his trailer while he was on set
working his butt off best cumberbatch
yeah
it can't be easy not having an acting
partner to give those authentic
performances i think it felt freeing for
him
to um get to be in other versions of
himself shoes but when you're a seasoned
pro it can't be too much of a challenge
either it's a bit clumsy and they went
it's great it's very unique it's
different number three just because
characters are in the same scene doesn't
mean they filmed on the same day despite
finally merging into the same cinematic
world elizabeth olsen never even met
some of the actors in the movie that
includes both john krasinski and patrick
stewart it was all done by the power of
movie magic i was just me and a green
screen and no other actor hug your ears
number four all these years later and
there's still new stunts to explore the
multiverse introduced new flying stunts
for elizabeth olsen there are ways we
use her flying that we haven't seen
before
you'd think olson would be a seasoned
veteran at this point and there wouldn't
be many flying stunts she hasn't done
before we are constantly impressed by
the innovation of marvel studios there
were a few rigs i'd never experienced
before on this number five this is the
doctor strange sequel that was made in
an alternate universe the original
script for doctor strange 2 was scrapped
when their director scott derrickson
quit just imagine what kind of movie we
would have if he'd stayed on board we
get the sense his version never brought
back dr palmer given she didn't get the
call for quite a while alas it is a
secret we will never be privy to
probably it's kind of got a little bit
of everything for everybody it's a bit
of a genre bust to this number six
usually reshoots spell trouble
doctor strange had six weeks of reshoots
in early 2022 so the release was pushed
to may they were working with an
incredibly complex plot and seeing as
it's paved the way for the next phase of
marvel it was important they get it
right i thought i would regret not doing
it more than i regret doing it even
though it makes me fringe a bit to watch
it reshoots were in response to test
screenings where they learned what
confused the audience and what moments
didn't land or were overexplained
raymie's first 2 hour and 40 minute cut
was trimmed down to two hours and ten
minutes that was before the reshoots
that replaced other scenes this is an
epic film fans of sam raimi are gonna
love it number seven actually we will
leave this to cumberbatch benedict
cumberbatch had to get ripped for the
doctor strange sequel and we gather
that's because for the first time he's
using his hands for more than just magic
but for fights as well as cumberbatch
put it there's a lot more that he's
asked to do in this and also some
physical stuff that doesn't involve
magic that is just about hand to hand
stuff there's a lot of reasons why i
like acting but one of them is to sort
of do things that are outside of my
comfort zone number eight good luck
you're going to need it raymie to
introduce beloved characters from the
x-men universe and fantastic four is a
lot of weight on sam raimi's shoulders
especially so after 2005's fantastic
four and the reboot now we've got
krazynski joining the movie as mr
fantastic and patrick stewart back as
professor x we've been waiting for this
day since disney acquired 21st century
fox way back in 2019 when it was still
stuck in the 20th century but honestly
we've really been waiting for like a
decade for this moment
number 9 the world has changed since
2001's spider-man sam raimi really
leaned into the horror in this one a
tone marvel hasn't really done in the
movies yet but despite what everyone
thinks he wasn't trying to force his own
directing style onto the movie
everything he did was in service of
doctor strange 2 not in service of him
and on set anyone will tell you he's a
fun and playful guy this movie was a
walk in the park for raymie compared to
spider-man back in 2001 he had to be a
lot more innovative the team had to make
the tools to make the tools and that was
an exhausting process but now that's all
been created and is at his disposal
thanks to the generous budget but
jumping into the universe after over a
decade of movies meant rainy had a team
of people behind him to make sure
nothing he wrote contradicted anything
in previous movies all of those things
were
giving us direction as to
where we should go number 10 playing two
versions of the same character is a
challenge rachel mcadams didn't know if
she would even be part of the multiverse
at first and when she first got the call
she was told she'd be playing three
different versions of herself which
thanks to the ever-changing script was
trimmed down to two her challenge with
playing the other christine was the fine
line between keeping palmer recognizable
and making this other one unsettling and
unnerving she really enjoyed getting out
of the hospital settings and seeing the
beautiful detail in the sets like the
sanctum sanctorum the sanctum is
extraordinary number 11. remember when
the world went weird over a teenage
peter parker sochi gomez played a
younger version of america chavez than
even the comics has ever done in this
movie we kind of get to have like a new
introduction to her it was a challenge
to keep america's personality the same
and what they found was they had to keep
the confidence and just make her less
experienced it's so crazy that i get to
be that person number 12 spoilers ahead
just kidding those already happened the
real villain for the production was
copied sort of it was more like an
anti-hero for sam raimi it gave him time
to rethink the script but they also
worked themselves to the bone trying to
accommodate all the covert requirements
so they could keep filming cumberbatch
said i lost count of how many lockdowns
we actually filmed through the reason
they were able to continue cumberbatch
said was this government's approved gold
standard of testing and tracing and a
huge amount of sacrifice
he admitted it's been tough i'll be
honest with you it's had quite a journey
this film it's been tough for everyone
i'm having a really good time being your
doctor strange and i enjoy it the
multiverse truly is mad you couldn't
have packed more chaos into the
pre-production if you tried do you think
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness was worth the chaos let us know
your thoughts in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things